关于荣国府内个人的收入状况,红楼第45回,曹雪芹借大观园诗设仇措设废,在经由王熙凤之口以李丸为例,详细解释了这位猪大嫂子的收入状况,原主是这么写的。
风景笑到,你一个月十两阴子的月前比我们多两倍阴子,老大的太太还说你管复失业的可怜不够用,又有个小子,足的又天了十两。
和老大的太太平等,又给你原子地,个人取猪子,年中分年历,你又是上上份。
你年而闷,主子奴菜共总没十个人,吃的穿的仍就是观中的,一年统功算起来也有四五百阴子。
按照这里的解释,李丸共存在三类收入,第一类就是固定的月前,每月二十两阴子和家母王夫人相等。
这当然是一种特殊情况,指因家母王夫人考虑到李丸丈夫去世,又有甲蓝要扶养,所以两次提升他的份力,长到如今的二十两阴子。
第二类是年中分年历,用今天的思维来理解就好比是年中讲,而且一般发放年历的时间是在年前。
屁如第49回,如雪广连施,奉借作为施设赞助商就差点来不了,原因就是,未发放年历正盟,此时随时冬季但却在年前,因为除夕过年发生在后来的第五十三回,所以年历发放一般是提前的,这跟今天的年中讲却是很像。
最难以理解的是第三类,王夕放说李丸有原子弟个人与孙子,可见李丸似乎单独拥有某片原地,并且出租出去以获得租金收益。
陈大康先生做荣国府的经济战役书,书中认为这块原子弟指的是道相村,不宏君个人是难以赞同的,我们先来看书中的观点。
在碳春改革大官员时,李丸只发表过一次意见,当时碳春晚夕横污院和遗宏院,这两处大地方竟没有出利息之物。
李丸当即纠正说,那两处花草都可卖钱,算起来比别的利息更大。
这一话题是由李丸所居住的道相村引起,先是一婆子深宝成包道相村的道田,表示愿意已交钱了。
接着考虑成包人选时,又提到道相村的菜书道败之类。
道相村一代的收益,原先都归李丸所有,第四十五回礼王夕峰与李丸交方时就说过,又给你原子弟个人取租子。
李丸提出横污院和遗宏院是收益最大之处,还有降低重人对道相村关注的意味。
尽管书中没有明言,但可以设想。
李丸一定会设法,让碳村和宝差明白,道相村的收益,原归自己所有的现状。
而最后的方案,也绝不会影响李丸原有的利益。
称大康先生此处,将原子理解城大官员,原子弟理解城道相村。
认为李丸一直战友着道相村,所产出的全部收益。
布红君思以为这是重大误读。
大官员又明醒清别术,乃是假家未迎接闲德飞员穿醒清,一时停留住毕之所。
等于半个皇家之地。
故而员飞醒清之后,立刻就被封锁起来,不令外人进入。
其后,宝差等子妹入住大官员,乃是员飞考虑道,自己信过之后,假正必定进行封锁,
不敢使人进去骚扰,起不了落。
皇家中现有几个能师会复的子妹,何不命他们进去居住,也不使家人落魄花流无言。
可见大官员的安置权,归员飞所有,只是暂时将使用权交给各位姐妹。
根本不存在,李丸将道相村,据为己有,甚至出租道相村原地以非己的情况。
特疑万不说,就算李丸有这个心思,家母假正王夫人也不会让他这么干,更不会主动给李丸大官员里的原子地。
三小姐探村改革大官员,在员内实施承包制,其直接目的是为了各处有专人管理。
如此员内花草数目一年好似一年,而且所用之人都是假家普人,也不存在外包的情况。
由大官员产生的道田,水果,花草,香料等收益,军由内部消化,不会损害醒清别墅的名声。
因此,我个人以为,陈大康先生的解读是有误的。
家母王夫人不会糊涂到,上次大官员里的地给李丸。
而李丸,仲然有另一色空门的缺点,终究为烈金零十二拆。
操工不会把它刻画的如此雕钻轨炸,供然清占大官员内的田地,以谋取苏京。
那么,王西方口中的原子地,以及苏字的说法到底指的是什么?
我们翻开红楼梦圆柱,地租的说法其实并不罕见。
第六回,刘劳劳依定荣国府时,借由周瑞家的引路。
周瑞家的介绍自己的丈夫,目前在荣府内的工作室,管春秋两季地租子,闲时时带着小延门出门。
在有第七十二回,家脸像冤阳借档,想把家母暂时用不着的经营家伙,搬几箱子出来点卖。
应付观众现金流短缺的环境。
家脸还给冤阳许下承诺说,即触房租地税通在九月才得,不上半年的光景,迎子来了我就熟了交还,断不能叫姐姐拉不是。
还有一处例子比较隐悔一些。第五是三回,宁国府除夕寂宗死。
装头污进校,带着鸡鸭猪鸯,以及满满的道迷古物,另有二千五百两赢子,来给宁国府送过年的年货。
人文社板红楼梦,对装头这个职位的解释是这样的。
装头,亲戴为满汉奇极贵族地主,经营其人田装的代理人。
装管监督,店户生产,催收地族,贪派楼意等市,有的装头本身就是地主。
通过这些例子我们能看出,您容梁府的租金收益具有多氧化的特征。
既由将田地租出去所产商的地族,也有将外面的房子出租收取租金的房子。
而且假脸说,几处房租地税,可见这些出租的房屋不止一处,甚至有可能不再同一个城市。
说中就曾提到,家母身边的一等压缓冤养,他的父母都在南京看房子。
假正痛打保育之后,家母也曾威胁说要坐车回南京,可见假家的房屋资产便不各处。
同时,您容梁府的具体负责人也不一样,您国府这边采用了污进效这样的专业装头,日常并不在您国府生活,每年固定来送年货和租金。
荣国府这边,则是王府任的陪房周瑞负责春秋地租,不用时刻盯着田地。
大概绿收完租金就回来了,毕竟家庭还在京都。
家母王府任给李完的原子地,大概绿是京都附近的地,便于李完即时收取租金。
李完作为荣府迪子假周的妻子,又给假家生下假篮,分房分地并不过分。
原住地久回旧记录了,宁府正派宣孙假强搬出府外居住,自立门户过活,假争就单独分与防射给他。
综合这些因素,我们就能感觉到。您容梁府就向两架巨大的机器,它运转的核心动力是经济因素,若是单靠假证公布原外狼的微博公司,根本撑不起假家这样的奢侈生活。
田里租金收益是其中的重要一环,而这部分收益又来自底层的百姓。
家府内养尊处优的贵族生活,踏着一家富贵万家窮的台阶。
假家已经富贵了五代,刘老老却说,荒年时还要肯数皮过火。
这是红楼梦义书,最值得深思的一个问题。
今天的红楼解读就聊到这里,我们下个视频再会。